your music is inspiring other young
women which is incredible but there's
one particular fan I love this story
that you helped recently right
absolutely yeah I feel like
um in a position on this story I feel
like we can be friends go okay yeah I
know when you saw it you're like oh
we're gonna hit it up yeah yeah
um I feel like I'm I'm starting to like
be in a position to where I can actually
give back and kind of help people yeah
up and it feels really nice I mean we're
even doing this emerging artist program
with Tractor Supply but this specific
story
um is so crazy we were in New York City
and I was playing
I'm on my very first headline and tour
right now yeah and congratulations
that's so cool it has been so awesome
but I see the sign out in the crowd and
I've got terrible Vision so I'm kind of
like squinting trying to see it and it
says will you sign my forehead and I'm
like
absolutely you better get up here I'm
gonna sign your forehead but when she
gets closer I realize that a week prior
this little girl had put up a tick tock
about people making fun of the way she
dressed she dressed like me at school
and you look like you're straight up out
of Fleetwood Mac I love your look yeah
and I think that kind of scares some
people but this little girl did not
scare her so when I realized that was
her I brought her up on stage and I had
her sign my forehead too
I love that yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
do you have a favorite moment with a fan
that you met like on a street or in a
convention or anything oh you probably
have many I don't know some interesting
ones yeah I think the one honestly the
the fan the ones that I remember the
most are when I meet people like at
conventions and things like that who
tell me that something that I've done
whether it's Chuck or Tangled or Shazam
or whatever like resonated with them on
a very deep level and helped them
through a time in their life that
otherwise would have been way too dark
you know like you know people losing
loved ones and then they they find Chuck
and it helped buoy their soul like that
as an artist
that's what you're hoping to do so
that's all the stuff that I remember the
most and people wanted me to sign their
babies faces but you know that's yeah
that's two thoughts
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
everybody